effort to improve student achievement
within ccsd the 2021 nevada legislative
session involved
a major infusion of funding 500 million
dollars slotted for education
including senate bills 222 and 318. now
the focus of these bills is to promote
nevada's diverse communities
senator fabian donate was behind sb 318
which strives to bridge the gap to
access good health care specifically
against covet
for those with limited english senator
melanie scheible was a sponsor of sb 222
that brings organizations together to
increase access and decrease racism
it is a fantastic bill to establish
diversity liaisons and government
agencies throughout the state
senator went on to point out that these
groups will convene to ensure they are
making headway and being more inclusive
at the signing the governor spoke about
the importance of these bills for
underserved communities
today's bill signing is a testament to
the office for new americans relentless
work
in immigrant and refugee advocacy and
our state's commitment to creating more
diverse
and welcoming state for everyone this
large amount of new funding will help
the state transition from the outdated
nevada plan to the new
pupil centered funding plan in addition
to this focus on diverse communities
other bills signed today were in support
of k-12 education
and firearms safety